Hey guys,
You know,
the role of a father is extremely important.
More than most men will ever realize.
Unfortunately, they only
realize it when it is too late.
And you can never go back.
You can never make it right again.
We have a fatherless problem in the world today.
And even when fathers are at home, a lot of them
are not really present.
Are you?
According to fatherly.com, kids who grow up
with a present, engaged dad are less likely
to drop out of school or wind up in jail,
compared to children with absent fathers
and no other male caretakers or role models.
When children have close relationships with father
figures they tend to avoid high risk behaviors.
And they're less likely
to have sex at a young age.
They're more likely to have high-paying jobs and
healthy, stable relationships when they grow up.
You see, the world is
downplaying the role of a father.
But the role of a father is extremely important.
Listen to the rest of this: They also tend to
have higher IQ test scores by the age of three,
and endure fewer psychological
problems throughout their lives.
When dads take the role of a father seriously,
altogether these benefits of having an
engaged dad are called the father effect.
Now, you might not have had a great father.
You know, an example.
But that is no excuse,
because as with everything in life, you
can always learn and improve yourself.
And there are many things that we can talk about
but I want to focus in on five extremely important
things that can help you to be a better father.
These are things that I experienced with my dad.
A dad who lived the way he preached.
He's not here anymore.
He passed away.
But all those things
he taught me changed my life forever.
Let's start with the first thing.
The first thing is: Follow God's Word because that
actually takes everything into account when you
want to be a good father.
Even the small things.
For example, the Bible says that
you have to be a man of your word.
That means including, when you
make promises to your children,
you should keep them.
That's what my dad did.
[James 5:12]
The biggest thing your child needs
from you is love, but also trust.
Trust.
If you don't keep your promises,
if your yes is not yes and your no is not
no, what do you think is going to happen?
They're not going to trust you, right?
And that's just one thing.
In the Word of God - follow God's Word
- and see how it will improve you to
become a better father.
Here's another example.
[Proverbs 20:7]
My dad lived according to God's Word
and that automatically made him a
man of integrity because he followed God's Word.
And me, being young, all those years growing
up, I saw how my dad lived with integrity.
That he was a doer of the
Word, and not just a hearer.
And today, I am blessed after him because
I saw all his decisions - experiences - and
actions - how he walked in integrity.
And I will never forget it.
Now, if you don't know God's
Word, then it is time to learn it.
[Psalm 119:105]
The world is full of darkness, as
your children will also experience,
but if you stay there in the darkness
trying to lead them, you will stumble.
You'll be lost.
And you will also cause them to be lost.
And that is where you will
stay - in darkness forever.
You need God's Word to be a lamp for your feet
on this earthly temporary journey so that you
can see the truth for yourself and walk towards
the destiny - the purpose - that God has for you.
If you follow God and His Word, God will bless
you, equip you with everything you need to take on
every obstacle that this life throws at you.
And you know, sometimes it
is not easy to raise children.
But God will help you with that as well.
[2 Timothy 3:16]
All of us - we are born as human
beings with a sinful nature.
Your kids - you never have to tell
them to be naughty - they just are.
Why?
Because of the sinful nature
in us that we are born with.
David said:
[Psalm 51:5}
Now, when we become reborn Christians,
we receive a new spiritual nature.
The Holy Spirit, right?
So we have that nature.
We also still have that old sinful flesh.
And when we act through the Spirit,
we will not sin.
This new nature helps us to overcome sin.
But when we don't act through the Spirit,
when we act through the flesh, we will sin.
We will fall and so not only not only
do we receive the new spiritual nature,
we also become children of God.
He adopts us after He declared us as righteous.
But that doesn't mean that when we sin, He will
just think okay, that's fine, and just leave it.
He disciplines us as a good
father because He loves us.
[Revelation 3:19]
And in the same way if you truly
love your children, you will also
discipline them if they are naughty or do evil.
Because if you don't, you're basically teaching
them that they can do evil, sinful things
with no consequences, so it's fine, go ahead.
[Proverbs 22:15]
So if you don't discipline
them, they will think they
can always get what they want, when they want.
They don't care who they hurt ... they can just
do whatever and they will get their desires.
No one stops me.
There's no consequences.
So why not, and then they
become extremely selfish.
And that's how they grow up.
And that's how they become - these mature men
and women walking around who are extremely
selfish and just care about themselves.
So if you don't care - if you don't truly
love your kids and you don't discipline them
- then this is what might happen to them.
So if you love them and truly care
about them, you will discipline them.
[Proverbs 13:24]
So think about it this way.
If you don't discipline them,
you actually nurture that sinful fleshly nature
of them even more and more so when they grow up,
they don't really care that much
about right and wrong anymore.
They're a bad husband, a bad father.
They do sleep around.
They do whatever they want at work.
They steal, they bribe, they do whatever they
want, because that's how you taught them.
It's okay, there's no consequences.
[Proverbs 29: 17]
[Proverbs 22:6]
Now this does not mean that you should
be harsh with them or provoke them to
anger or beat them blue and purple.
That is not what God's Word says.
But depending on their personality, you need
to discipline them with wisdom and love.
[Ephesians 6:4]
You know, I was always busy and naughty,
so my dad, he would keep his word.
He would give me three warnings, but if I
didn't listen, he said he is going to spank
me after the third time, and he always did.
That gave me security - a kind of structure to
know there's always consequences and also
to know that my dad will keep his word.
And afterward, you know,
after I cried, he spanked me.
He would explain to me exactly again to make
sure that I know why he gave me a spanking.
What I did was wrong and I needed to
apologize and when I did that, he hugged me.
He told me he loves me.
The relationship is restored again.
Father - son.
And then I continued, but I learned my lesson.
Those three warnings gave me structure - security.
There are a lot of people who scream at
their kids and they threaten them.
Seven, eight, nine, ten times - if you
do this again I'm going to do this and that and
you don't do that and so there's no structure.
Sometimes you say it three times.
Sometimes 15.
So that means you don't keep your word.
If you say to your child - if you do
this again I am going to discipline you -
then you need to keep your word and do it.
They need that structure to know that
when you say something as their parent
that you will do what you said you will do.
There's a difference between being a friend
to your child which you also need to be and then
that authority where they learn respect for you.
[Hebrews 12:11]
You know, some parents are
against disciplining their kids.
And you can just see how those kids - they
have no respect for their parents - but they
then scream at their kids - scream and loud,
you know, psychological abuse is a lot worse.
[Colossians 3:21]
So, discipline your children in love.
If they did something bad after you warn
them a few times, let's say the third time, you
discipline them and just don't leave it there.
Just don't discipline them and walk away.
No.
Talk to them, have a conversation, make sure they
understand why you discipline them and tell them
to apologize and then give them a hug.
Give them a kiss.
Restore that relationship.
And then you continue.
You need to do that in the same
way that God is now your Father.
You are His child.
And so when you go and you do something bad,
you come back and you say you're sorry.
He forgives you, and you continue.
Say sorry.
Apologize.
Ask forgiveness.
It's not just your kids who need to apologize.
And ask you for forgiveness
when they do something wrong.
You need to set the example.
There's no such thing as a perfect father.
We all know that.
You will make mistakes and then they look
at you - your kids they look at how you act.
So you can't expect them to
say sorry if you don't do it.
So if you did something wrong, own that mistake.
Apologize.
Ask them to forgive you.
Never just ignore it because if
you do, your kids will do the same.
[James 5:16]
You know, my dad would always do this.
And for a lot of men this might
be difficult because of pride.
They wrongly think that if they do this - if
they apologize to their kids - then they would
think less of them and that's because of pride.
The sinful flesh.
It's actually the opposite.
For example, my dad would come
if he and my mom had words.
For example, in the kitchen and we were there we
saw this conversation, he would come back later
and he would apologize to her and also to us.
He would say something like, you know,
even if what I said was right, the way
I spoke to your mother was not right.
Please forgive me.
And then we would and
that made me respect him so so much more.
And that example helps even me today in my
marriage and with all other relationships - to own
my mistakes - to say I am sorry when I'm wrong.
It's easy not to do it - to just ignore it, right?
That's easy,
because it's part of the sinful flesh.
But it's through the spirit that you will go and
make things right between you and your family.
Own your mistakes, set that example,
and your kids will follow.
There will be this openness - this
beautiful love - where people are humble and
there's no place for sin or the devil to creep
in and break up that family because of pride.
Put your family first - not yourself or
other things.
Put them first.
It's one of the reasons I loved my dad so much.
You know, he would he would give his last money
or take off his clothes just so that
we could go and study and get degrees.
He did everything for us and he
didn't even think about it twice.
There were so many things that
he sacrificed from his own life
that now that he passed away I'm starting to
remember things and I appreciate it so much.
[Philippians 2:3]
Pride and selfishness can always
come between you and your kids.
It will prevent you from
having a good relationship.
For example, pride stops
you from asking forgiveness.
Selfishness prevents you from
putting your children up as one
of the highest priorities in your life.
And ignorance stops you from spending
enough quality time with them because
you think they need your money more.
You know, as a reborn Christian, you have the
Holy Spirit in you, which means loving them.
Your family.
It's not just when
you want to - it's an act of your will.
It's agape love, unconditional love.
There's storge love as well and
philia, which means there's friendship
love and family love, right?
Eros love is sexual love and
that comes only together with your wife, right?
But all the others, is with you and your kids.
And you need to do that always, even when you
see your children need to spend time with you,
even when you're tired and don't feel like it.
There are moments in your life when you need
to sacrifice your own feelings
and give them what they need.
And the moment you put on that switch, when you
act through the Spirit, you will suddenly see that
your whole soul - your emotions - your intellect
- your own will - just comes together and now
you want to spend time with them.
You know, my dad did not always
have a lot of money.
But he tried his best
even though he was very busy to always take
time and spend time with us as his kids.
We are five kids - five very different
personalities - and he tried to connect
with each one of us on our level
with our different personality.
Your children should not learn to become a great
man or woman from school or from their friends.
They learn it from you.
Their identity - they get that from you.
Money - it's going to make things worse.
They need you - time with you - and if you
don't spend time with them, how are you going
to know what they truly need and how to spend
time with them specifically?
And how are you going to put
them first in your life - truly?
Let me ask you a few questions.
Do you even know the favorite colors of your kids?
What are their favorite hobbies?
What do they like?
What don't they like?
And do they know those things of you?
Do they know you?
Make time for your kids.
Time passes so quick... and
one of these days they'll be mature and
then when you look back in your life,
those thoughts would come and you would think,
man, I should have spent more time with them.
I should have gone more fishing.
I should have done this more.
I should have done that more.
Well, now you still have time.
You can't go back right now into the past,
but you have time to do things right now.
So act now and don't wait for regret.
Let's move on to the next one.
Number five: Love them and make
sure that they know you love them.
You know, my dad wasn't a perfect father
because there's no such thing, as we said
at the beginning of this video.
But he was near because
he lived the way he preached.
When he made mistakes, he would come back,
ask forgiveness and make it right.
And he would always make sure
that we know that he loved us.
Do your kids know that you love them?
They're not going to know it through
you buying them gifts or taking
them fishing or doing other things for them.
They might even get too spoiled and not appreciate
things enough if you always just give them stuff.
You need to tell them you love
them from your lips.
They need to hear it.
Some parents might be a little bit hesitant or
afraid, you know, if they are going to be too
strict - or not strict - but tell them don't do
this, don't do that, then they might think you
don't love them anymore.
No.
You love them if you discipline them.
You can tell them the truth of certain things when
they go off the right path, you know. They make
their own decisions, especially when they grow up,
and then you leave them but you still tell
them this is right - this is wrong - with love.
And when you tell them that, they should
never feel that you don't love them anymore.
That you don't care about them.
God our Father is a good example.
He loves us and we know it.
But He doesn't love our sin.
[Romans 5:8]
Love them and keep on praying for them.
Always let them know that
you're praying for them as well.
You know, my story was like
the story of the prodigal son.
I knew my parents loved me and I also
knew that they were praying for me.
I went away but you know God was
working in me and I think it's
because of those prayers and I came back.
So let them know that you pray for them.
Do not quarrel unnecessarily with your kids.
Always tell them, oh don't do this,
don't do this, don't do this.
Show them love as well.
There needs to be a balance.
Tell them the truth in love
but then continue the relationship with them as
well so that they will know that you love them.
God gave them free will to make their own
decisions so let them make their own decisions
as God lets you make your own decisions.
But we know what God's Word says.
We know what He wants from us, and it's
the same thing with you and your kids.
You tell them this is right, this is wrong.
But then, when they get that certain age,
you kind of have to let them go.
When they leave the nest.
But never stop to be a good example.
And always pray for them.
[1 Timothy 2:8]
[1 Thessalonians 5:17]
[James 5:16]
Now remember, there is no such
thing as a perfect father.
Only God the Father - He is a perfect father.
And we can try our best to follow His example.
Now, go and be a great father, and
always remember, that life is short.
So don't waste yours, because what will
your kids think of you when you're not
here anymore?
Cheers guys.